nice guy
he is the Guinness World Record holder
for the tallest living male dog he is he
is
when people meet Zeus they ask
um is that a horse if we ride him
um we have a lot of people that say do
you have a saddle for him
because he's you know they think he's a
horse
he just kept growing and honestly it was
one of my family members that said we
think he's the tallest dog in the world
you should measure him because I see him
every day I know he's big but I didn't
know he was
you know so we measured him and he was
the tallest
wow really easy for you less mess
he's so big it's hard to make him do
anything yeah can you sit good boy here
we go oh it could be really that he's
the tallest dog ever it's possible yes
we're really excited about that that
would
um
that would give him a title that he will
probably hold forever it'll be a lasting
memory